-We love you and your family,
and they've said some things
over the years that have
become iconic quotes.
-Okay.
-And so we wanted to put
your knowledge to the test in
a new game called "Who Said It?"
-Perfect.
♪ -Who said it? ♪
♪ Tell me who said it ♪
-Why am I nervous?
-How it works is I'm going to
read you real quotes that you,
your sisters, or your mom, Kris,
have said,
and you have to tell me
who said it.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-I feel like I'm not going to be
good at this.
-First up, here we go.
Who said, "Would you stop taking
pictures of yourself?
Your sister's going to jail."
[ Laughter ]
-That is actually one of
my favorite moments,
so I know exactly who this is.
It was my mom.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Let's see who said it.
Here we go.
-Kim, would you stop taking
pictures of yourself?
Your sister's going to jail.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
♪♪
-Who said, "Honey, would you put
a bumper sticker on a Bentley?"
-Kim. That was her thing
she would always say.
-Let's see who said it.
-Honey, would you put a bumper
sticker on a Bentley?
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
Good, you got two.
[ Applause ]
This one might be
my favorite one.
Who said, "You're cute jeans."
-Me.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you're right.
Let's see who said it.
-Those are cute jeans.
-You're cute jeans.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I don't even know,
like, what that was.
-Dude, that was just
saying to your mom
that you love her, yeah.
-Exactly.
-She's cute.
Those are cute jeans.
You're cute jeans.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that.
That's my favorite quote.
Who said, "But just knowing
you're a badass bitch
is just all what life is about."
-I really don't know this one.
Oh, no.
-"Just knowing
you're a badass bitch
is just all what life is about."
-Khloe. I'll guess Khloe.
-Let's see who said it.
-But just knowing
you're a badass bitch
is just all what life is about."
-That's what I'm talking about.
It was Khloe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Of course it was.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, no.
-This might be
my other favorite.
"You're cute jeans" is my other,
but this one is a great quote.
"A, B, C, D, E, F, G,
I have to go."
[ Laughter ]
-It's Kourtney and it's so good.
-Watch this.
-A, B, C, D, E, F, G,
I have to go.
-What the heck does
A, B, C, D, E, F, G mean?
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's really good.
-What does that have to do --
-Scott's reaction is everything.
-Scott was like,
"What's A, B, C, D, E, F, G?"
-By the way, you have to find
the extended clips of all these
because they end up getting into
funny moments afterwards.
It's really good.
-But did she forget H?
Is that the way it works?
Like, "A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H,
I have to go."
-Oh! Yeah, I feel like she did
say it wrong, by the way,
'cause I think it was
a meme or a quote.
-I don't know what it is
but I love it.
-And she tried to use it
and kind of botched it,
but it became a whole thing.
It's all over TikTok, I guess.
-It's all over TikTok, yeah.
I love that one, though.
That and "you're cute --" Oh.
Who said, "Rise and shine"?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, this one's --
Kylie, obviously.
-Yeah, here we go.
-This one's good.
-Let's take a look.
♪ -Rise and shine ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
Kendall Jenner!
Her new tequila 818
is available now.